kahlschlag bei karstadt kaufhof 62
warenhäuser machen dicht 6000
beschäftigte verlieren ihre jobs
erfolg für andreas kalbitz ein gericht
erklärt den rauswurf des früheren
brandenburger fdp chefs für unzulässig
und schlachtbetrieb turniers in der
kritik bei kontrollen im mai wurden
mängel bei den abstandsregeln
festgestellt
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara wegen willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
schön dass sie dabei sind wie auch
norbert lehmann für den spachtel und so
von mir
dieser tag wird spuren hinterlassen in
vielen innenstädten und bei den
betroffenen mitarbeitern erst recht
karstadt kaufhof die letzte große
warenhauskette deutschlands hat ihre
sanierungspläne bekannt gegeben
demnach werden 62 filialen geschlossen
110 bleiben vorerst bestehen allein in
berlin machen sechs filialen zu stark
betroffen ist auch nordrhein-westfalen
in essen und in dortmund schließen
jeweils beide häuser in münchen 3
besonders bitter sind die schließungen
für strukturschwache städte wie besser
oder worms tadeusz parade berichtet
essen trifft es besonders hart
laut zdf informationen soll die stadt im
ruhrgebiet beide waren häuser verlieren
jahrzehntelang prägten sie das essener
zentrum die mitarbeiter geschockt war
schon mal dass beide häuser geschlossen
wird man konnte sich vielleicht denken
das eigene haus geschlossen wird aber
dass beide häuser geschlossen werden
damit hat keiner gerechnet
während der korona krise hatte der
warenhaus-konzern galeria karstadt
kaufhof einen schutzschirm verfahren
beantragt das ergebnis 62 von insgesamt
172 standorten sollen schließen
das management waffe eine offizielle
stellungnahme nicht zu erreichen
laut gewerkschaft sondern und 6.000
vollzeitstellen gestrichen haben und
deswegen war es für uns von enormer
bedeutung
eine transfergesellschaft zu vereinbaren
dies zumindest für die ersten sechs
monate die menschen am übergang
verschafft doch die krise der
warenhäuser
sie hatte schon lange vor corinna
begonnen internet und online handel ist
sicherlich eine facette aber nicht die
einzige vor allem die filialisierten
händler die großen filialisten haben
massiv an marktanteile dazugewonnen und
der kuchen bleibt immer gleich es wird
im endeffekt wurde es von den
warenhäusern weggenommen und die
entwicklung bei absehbar
das sind essen die warenhäuser bald nur
noch geschichte sind für kunden kaum
vorstellbar
also ist es ist ja für mich ist das
einfach ein kollateralschaden von corona
da geht etwas verloren und wir wir
dürfen sich gefallen lassen
besonders für strukturschwache städte
könnte das aus noch weitreichende folgen
haben wenn man weiter bedenkt dass wir
von 50.000 weiteren pleiten in folge von
krone und online handel ausgehen dann
droht eine verödung der innenstädte
kommenden montag muss der
gläubigerausschuss dem insolvenzplan
zustimmen falls nicht könnten die zahlen
sogar noch dramatischer ausfallen
kriterien in worms was bedeutet das für
eine stadt wie worms und ihre bürger
wenn der kaufhof schließt ja warum es
das ja eine von vielen mittelgroßen
städten in deutschland rund 87.000
einwohner und keine wirklich große city
und deshalb wird die angekündigte
schließung der galeria kaufhof filiale
hinter mir wohl große folgen für die
stadt haben das haben ganz viele
menschen erzählt die heute hier vorbei
gegangen sind und mit denen ich
gesprochen habe
trotz online-handel sei diese filiale
der zentrale anlaufpunkt für zum
einkaufen für worms aber auch für ganz
viele leute aus den vororten und ganz
viele geschäftliche ringsherum
profitierten bisher von der kundschaft
die durch diese filiale angezogen wurde
und die jetzt wahrscheinlich aus bleibt
insofern die betroffenheit über die
angekündigte schließung ist groß aber
mindestens genauso groß ist auch die
sorge um den weiteren bestand der
geschäfte hier in der wormser city
eindrücke aus worms vielen dank boxx
cheney zur afd
vor vier wochen hatte der vorstand
andreas kalbitz aus der afg geworfen
weil der angeblich bei seinem
parteieintritt eine mitgliedschaft in
der verbotenen rechtsextremen
heimattreuen deutschen jugend
verschwiegen hatte dagegen wehrte sich
der ehemalige brandenburger parteichef
mit einem eilantrag vor gericht und
hatte zumindest damit heute erfolg er
darf in der afg bleiben vorerst
jedenfalls nicole diekmann mit details
die rechtsaußen in der afg haben heute
etwas zu feiern andreas kalbitz darf
erstmal zurück in die partie
er führte zusammen mit böcker den
inzwischen aufgelösten partei flügel vom
verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft die
entscheidung des berliner gerichts dass
der bundesvorstand keilwitz
mitgliedschaft unrechtmäßig für nichtig
erklärt hat ein etappensieg für kids und
rückenwind
meine priorität lag immer in der sache
orientierten und konstruktiven
zusammenarbeit die frage der
verantwortung müssen sich die stellen
die diese fehlentscheidung verantwortet
haben parteichef leuten hatte die knappe
mehrheit vor vier wochen gegen cables
organisiert er will die heutige
entscheidung nicht als sieg für kids
verstanden wissen
das werden sicherlich einige gerne so
sehen aber so ist es mir das gericht hat
klar gesagt in der sache selbst muss das
bundesschiedsgericht entscheiden dass
wir das tun
bis dahin dürfte sie selbst für ihre
verhältnisse massiv gespaltener afd
weiter streiten ob die gräben überhaupt
noch überwindbar sind vermag heute
niemand zu sagen
das ist eine schwierige frage die sie
mehr stellen
von mir aus immer und ich glaube auch
schon frei weise wenn man das so sagen
darf unser haben copala auch aber
diejenigen die mit juristisch
fragwürdigen mitteln versuchen jemanden
auszuschließen müssen sie überlegen wie
sie jetzt weiter mit diesem thema
umgehen nicht mein morgens kupfer sitzen
da stellt sich heute hinter ihnen
mussten zurücktreten
das entscheide ich nicht kann sie
fordern sie sind ja immerhin co
vorsitzender der partei
da sage ich jetzt nichts die afd
eine partei im umfragetief und inmitten
eines machtkampfs bei denen die
rechtsaußen heute einen punkt sieg
eingefahren haben
herr nachfrage bei theo koll in berlin
was bedeutet dieser juristische erfolg
von kallwitz für parteichef leuten
es wird auf jeden fall leuten oder alle
seine unterstützer im parteivorstand
schwächen denn sie waren sich in der
sache sicher haben sich aber juristisch
offensichtlich verschätzt aber das gilt
nur bis zu einer entscheidung des
bundesschiedsgerichts der afg sollte
dort mehrheitlich entschieden werden
dass kallwitz aus der partei
ausgeschlossen wird dann wäre das
heutige urteil nur ein pyrrhussieg für
kallwitz gewesen denn das kammergericht
hat heute nicht in der sache entschieden
das ging
nur um den verfahrensfehler das nicht
der parteivorstand sondern das
schiedsgericht für die beendigung einer
mitgliedschaft zuständig ist was
bedeutet das ganze wird die
rechtsextreme strömungen in der partei
wenn wir jetzt an macht gewinnen
kurzfristig auf jeden fall die
rücktrittsforderungen gegen leuten
werden von den kalbitz anhängerin jetzt
sehr laut werden alexander gauland hatte
ja schon gedroht die andere seite solle
sich warm anziehen wenn der rauswurf
juristisch nicht hält heute schreibt
gerade schon willkommen zurück kallwitz
für das machtgefüge wird wichtig sein
wie das afg schiedsgericht entscheidet
und ob kalbitz wirklich bleibt in jedem
fall aber vertieft sich der riss in der
ard dass der gesamte landesverband in
brandenburg seit ein paar tagen wegen
rechtsextremistischer tendenzen unter
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes
steht das glaube ich schwächt die
rechtsextrem mehr als die heutige
entscheidung ihn nutzt dankeschön nach
berlin theo koll nach europa wie kann
die eu in der korona pandemie
solidarität zeigen und den besonders
betroffenen mitgliedstaaten helfen
zum ersten mal haben die staats und
regierungschefs heute per video über den
gigantischen wiederaufbau plan beraten
den die kommission vorgeschlagen hat
dabei geht es um hilfen in höhe von 750
milliarden euro 500 milliarden davon
sollen als zuschüsse gewährt werden 250
milliarden als kredite die zurückgezahlt
werden müssen allerdings ist vieles an
dem plan umstritten stefan leifert
berichtet
italien hat den locker und hinter sich
die krise aber noch lange nicht dass
corona gebeutelte land wartet auf
touristen auf kunden und auf hilfe aus
europa damit die wirtschaft wieder fahrt
aufnimmt
normalerweise ist juni die beste zeit
für uns die wärme bringt leute dazu ihre
haare schneiden zu lassen war diesmal
ist alles anders wir haben kaum arbeit
sehr sehr wenig arbeit über zu wenig
arbeit können sich europas
regierungschefs nicht beklagen
zum fünften mal tagen sie per
videoschalte um milliarden hilfen für
die wirtschaft zu debattieren auch heute
ohne einigung
die brücken die wir noch zu bauen haben
sind groß das ist ohne frage richtig
aber es war eine diskussion in einem
sehr in einer sehr konstruktiven
atmosphäre
zwar sollen die hilfen aus brüssel
schnell in die krisenländer fließen aber
umstritten noch fast alles das volumen
des fonds das verhältnis von
zurückzuzahlen den krediten und
zuschüssen vergabekriterien dauer der
hilfen und länge der rückzahlungen des
table
ich werde jetzt konkrete vorschläge auf
den tisch legen damit wir schnell zu
einer einigung kommen uns ist klar dass
wir so schnell wie möglich entscheiden
müssen immerhin einen namen ein logo und
ein riesenplakat gibt es schon für
brüssels milliarden planen so gewaltig
das programm so gewaltig auch die
differenzen zwei sich die eu im
grundsatz einig aber in so gut wie jedem
detail noch zerstritten
der heutige video gipfel war erst der
anfang der debatte europa steht ein
hitziger sommer bevor und auch das eine
folge von corona die steuereinnahmen
gehen massiv zurück bund und länder
bekamen im mai im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat fast 20 prozent weniger
beim bund lag das minus sogar bei fast
35 prozent
vor allem die einnahmen von umsatz und
lohnsteuer sanken weil viele unternehmen
ihre mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit schicken
mussten die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland steigt derzeit wieder wegen
mehrerer lokale ausbrüche im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 450 menschen
sich neu mit dem virus angesteckt
gestern lag die zahl noch bei 300 der
anstieg kommt auch durch die jetzt mehr
als 800 infektionen beim schlachtbetrieb
turniers im kreis gütersloh
insgesamt stehen dort 7000 menschen
unter quarantäne
der betroffene betrieb steht seit
mittwoch still
mittlerweile gibt es schwere vorwürfe
gegen das unternehmen
hygiene regeln nicht eingehalten zu
haben schon im mai waren mängel
festgestellt worden
thomas münten hat details heute morgen
traf ein sanitätszug der bundeswehr in
rheda wiedenbrück 1 13 soldaten sollen
den kreis gütersloh beim testen der
insgesamt 7000 ähnliches mitarbeiter
unterstützen
ich habe mir sagen lassen dass man so
die rund 1200 testungen am tag
durchführen kann und das ist schon eine
ordentliche anzahl der schlachtruf steht
still eine katastrophe für die bauern im
umland sie können ihre tiere nicht
anliefern jeden tag werden die ställe
voller wenn die tiere immer weniger
platz haben und wir kriegen die gesagt
in der nächsten woche wahrscheinlich
wieder ansteigende temperaturen dann
wird das ein problem werden
ein möglicher infektions ort könnte die
tönnies werkskantine hier bilder
offenbar von ende märz gewesen sein
bei zwei kontrollen saßen die
mitarbeiter in der kantine zu eng
nebeneinander
der kreis gütersloh kontrolliert
unterdessen die umsetzung der quarantäne
und bisher nur mit stichproben einige
der betroffenen arbeiter sehen den sinn
der maßnahme nicht ein
viele der leiharbeiter haben inzwischen
den eigentlich verbotenen heimweg
angetreten der wärme bürgermeister
michael esken lässt die quarantäne
unterkünfte deshalb von einem wachdienst
überprüfen werden menschen die infiziert
sind durch ganz europa geschickt
ich mag mir gar nicht vorstellen was
alles passieren kann
wir haben mir zeitnah gehandelt ich
hoffe dass es nicht zu spät war am
frühen abend trat der ministerpräsident
in düsseldorf wo die presse gemeinsam
mit den ordnungskräften soll die
quarantäne durchgesetzt werden
wir appellieren an alle
diese quarantäne auch einzuhalten
und wenn sie nicht eingehalten wird
werden wir mit allen uns zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln diese quarantäne
durchsetzen am sonntagabend will die
landesregierung in einer videoschaltung
über das weitere vorgehen entscheiden
auch ein totaler lockdown in der region
gütersloh ist nicht ausgeschlossen
mit am stärksten betroffen von corona
ist die luftfahrtbranche zwar rollt der
flugverkehr langsam wieder an die
beschäftigten sorgen sich dennoch um
ihre arbeitsplätze
die gewerkschaft verdi hatte zur
bundesweiten protestaktionen an mehreren
flughäfen aufgerufen
insgesamt beteiligten sich etwa 1300
teilnehmer ein milliardenschweres
rettungspaket soll zumindest der
lufthansa aus der krise helfen
dem müssen noch die aktionäre zustimmen
und auch noch diese wirtschaftsnachricht
vom dax-konzern wirecard mitten im
bilanzskandal ist der firmengründer und
konzernchef des finanzdienstleisters
markus braun zurückgetreten hinteren
chef wird der us manager james freys der
erst gestern in den vorstand berufen
worden war
das unternehmen aus bayern ist massiv
unter druck geraten weil ein angebliches
guthaben von fast zwei milliarden euro
nicht aufzufinden ist im kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornographie
wollen innenminister von bund und
ländern die umstrittene
vorratsdatenspeicherung einsetzen
unerlässlich sein mindestspeicherfristen
um täter ausfindig zu machen und
schreckliche taten zu verhindern sagt
innenminister seehofer allerdings haben
mehrere gerichte die anlasslose
datenspeicherung als verfassungswidrig
eingestuft der bundespräsident macht mit
vereine kommunen und unternehmen ebenso
beim ersten bundesweiten digital tag das
ziel alle menschen in deutschland sollen
die chancen der digitalisierung besser
verstehen und daran teilhaben können
allerdings ist der zugang zu schnellem
internet mit mindestens 50 megabit pro
sekunde sehr ungleich verteilt in großen
städten können über 95 prozent der
haushalte mit highspeed surfen in
ländlichen gebieten
dagegen wie hier in sachsen anhalt kann
das nicht einmal die hälfte
was das bedeutet zeigt hagen nicolas das
kabel fürs schnelle internet liegt an
der hauswand doch noch wartet die
förderschule in klein oschersleben auf
den anschluss die fünfte klasse bereitet
online die aufgaben für die kommende
homeschooling woche vor doch das
internet ist derzeit ein großes problem
das heißt im haus 4 und haus 5 aber gar
kein internet also da können die kinder
und die lehrer diese sachen nicht üben
und auch nicht für den unterricht nutzen
ich habe auch manchmal flexible kollegen
die in hot spot mit ihren eigenen
geräten dann machen
das passiert auch laptops online
lernplattform und wlan vieles hat die
förderschule selbst organisiert etwa mit
hilfe einer finnischen schule auf
schnelles internet aber warten sie hier
seit drei jahren kein einzelfall in ganz
sachsen anhalt haben nur 30 der über 800
schulen einen glasfaseranschluss denn
der ausbau der breitband anschlüsse in
sachsen anhalt kam im vergangenen jahr
nur in einem landkreis wesentlich voran
der glasfaserausbau ist ein bundesweites
problem
2009/10 verdoppelte sich die anzahl der
anschlüsse in nur wenigen landkreisen
hier dunkelblau gezeichnet und das trotz
einer schon 2015 beschlossenen
milliarden förderung kritisiert die
digitalwirtschaft wir haben von der
investitionsseite er einiges gutes getan
aber die genehmigungsverfahren dauert
viel zu lange sind viel zu bürokratisch
und wir brauchen viel zu lange um auch
die wirklich die glasfaser kabel in die
erde zu bekommen
doch in sachsen-anhalt tut sich was bis
jahresende sollen knapp die hälfte der
schulen am glasfasernetz sein
die förderschule in klein quenstedt ist
eine davon zum nächsten schuljahr hoffen
sie hier das schnelle internet endlich
nutzen zu können
weiterhin versuchen migranten über das
mittelmeer nach europa zu kommen das
rettungsschiff swatch 3 hat mehr als 200
menschen an bord genommen
sie seien vor der libyschen küste von
drei booten gerettet worden erklärten
die deutschen helfer jetzt wird ein
sicherer hafen gesucht italien hatte
zuletzt migranten erst nach längeren
verhandlungen und quarantäne an land
gelassen
der wohl erfolgreichste spanische
schriftsteller der gegenwart ist tot
carlos ruiz zafón ist mit 55 jahren an
krebs gestorben in seiner wahlheimat los
angeles
sein berühmtestes buch ist der schatten
des windes nach don quichotte der
meistverkaufte spanische roman daraus
zitiert der verlage safins tod jedes
buch hat eine seele die seele dessen der
es geschrieben hat und die seele derer
die es gelesen und davon geträumt haben
ja sehr schönes buch übrigens und jetzt
sind wir beim sport basketball
bundesliga finalturnier da gibt es eine
handfeste überraschung denn der deutsche
meister bayern münchen
er ist ausgeschieden der hatte das
viertelfinal-hinspiel gegen überraschend
starke ludwigsburger mit vier punkten
unterschied verloren im rückspiel heute
siegten die bayern zwar aber es reichte
nicht
nationalspieler paul zipser punktet
reichlich für die bayern zu beginn gegen
ludwigsburg in gelb die den vier punkte
vorsprung aus dem hinspiel schnell
einbüßen bei halbzeit die bayern 9
punkte voraus uli hoeneß ist begeistert
ludwigsburg offensiv lange nicht so gut
wie im hinspiel drei punkte würfe
klappen erst gar nicht dann spät jetzt
italiens mails ludwigsburg führt auf
einmal im schlussviertel
die bayern kommen noch mal gewinnen das
spiel 74 73 aber nicht hoch genug denn
ludwigsburg ist dank des 4 punkte
hinspielsiegs im halbfinale die bayern
die zuletzt 2012 im viertelfinale
ausgeschieden
nationalspieler leroy sany will seinen
bis 2021 laufenden vertrag bei
manchester city nicht verlängern
das bestätigte city coach pep guardiola
heute und sagte er könnte den klub im
sommer verlassen wenn man sich mit einem
anderen verein bei der ablösesumme
geeinigt sande ist wunschkandidat von
bayern münchen
ja am morgen vorletzter spieltag in der
fußball-bundesliga spannung total im
tabellenkeller
wenn bremen in mainz verliert und
düsseldorf augsburg besiegt ja dann ist
für werder der erste abstieg seit 40
jahren besiegelt langsam wird's
ungemütlich trainer co feld kämpft mit
bremen gegen den abstieg gegen meister
bayern am dienstag trotz couragierten
auftritts nichts mitgenommen jetzt muss
gepunktet werden nur mit einem ziel
nochmals dazu gewinnen und dann haben am
letzten spieltag egal was kommt egal wie
die andern ergebnis ist egal wie
düsseldorf dann spielt wir haben am
letzten spieltag eine situation in der
für alle drei mannschaften da unten noch
alles mögliche gegner mainz hat nach dem
überraschenden sieg in dortmund
matchball im abstiegsrennen wäre mit
einem sieg sicher gerettet es wird eng
im keller gewinnen weil wir müssen die
voraussetzungen schaffen und dann danach
gucke ich auf die tabelle
einfach so abgehen keine option für
bremen das ziel glückwünsche nicht nur
verteilen sondern am saisonende selbst
entgegennehmen da morgen die so
erzeugten und passend dazu noch was zum
thema geht nicht gibt's nicht weil
corona bedingt alle flüge nach
argentinien gestrichen waren stieg ein
argentinia in sein kleines boot und
segelte allein von portugal nach hause
weil er unbedingt noch mal seine
hochbetagten eltern sehen wollte nach 85
tagen und gut 8000 kilometern erreichte
er den hafen seiner heimatstadt mar del
plata jetzt muss der 47 jährige
allerdings noch zwei wochen in
quarantäne dann endlich darf er seine
eltern in die arme schließen und die top
nachricht von katja der hochsommer kommt
nächste woche am wochenende sind
allerdings noch einige schauer unterwegs
mehr dazu gleich beim wetter marietta
slomka freut sich auf 17 im heute
journal
und wir wünschen ihnen ein richtig
schönes wochenende und freuen uns wenn
sie uns morgen wieder aufmerksamkeit
widmen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
mit abend meine damen und herren wie in
zeitlupe zieht dieses wolkenband ganz
allmählich weiter nach norden
es hat in den vergangenen 24 stunden
noch einmal kräftige regenfälle gebracht
zum beispiel im süden hamburgs aber auch
in brandenburg und in sachsen
und jetzt am nachmittag gab es auch noch
einige gewitter zb in bayern gewitter
müssen wir in dieser nacht nicht mehr
befürchten hier nordöstlich der elbe
lassen auch die regenfälle mehr und mehr
nach sonst ist es zum teil auch klar es
gibt noch einige regenschauer und die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen
16 und 8 grad morgen liegen sie dann
meist knapp über 20 grad mit kleineren
ausnahmen zum beispiel an der ostsee
nordfriesland und am alpenrand bleibt es
bei 19 grad etwas kühler
morgen fällt noch etwas regen hier im
äußersten osten und da sind auch noch
mal einzelne gewitter dabei sonst aber
wird zum teil schon sehr freundlich hier
zwischen schleswig holstein und
nordrhein westfalen aber auch am
oberrhein am sonntag beschränkten sich
einzelne regenfälle wirklich hier auf
den äußersten osten zwischen usedom und
dem ruder buch oder auch im
berchtesgadener land richtung
wettersteingebirge die temperaturen
steigen auf 20 bis 26 grad und in der
neuen woche wird sehr sonnig und von tag
zu tag wärmer
schönen abend noch